the situation is dire Emperor Zayn seeks
to slake his thirst for revenge with the
heart of an Curia in the city of alias a
small group of heroes must thus stand
against an entire empire the time for
resistance is now
hi there it's kevin van ORD standing in
for reviewer brett todd to tell you
about sacred 3 what's in a name if you
take the example of sacred 3 pretty much
nothing this game may bear the name of
an action role-playing series but it's
actually more of a half-hearted gauntlet
clone this mediocre button masher strips
out just about everything that makes
click fest rpgs worth clicking around in
a script inspired by equal measures of
Tolkien and Leisure Suit Larry is the
first big problem at first it seems like
you're stepping into the brawny boots of
the usual hero in the usual elves and
orcs saga the fate of the realm of
Arcania is at stake here and Lord Zayn
and his ashen empire are pillaging towns
innocents are being slaughtered undead
are rising weirdly enough though these
events are all played for laughs this is
one of the most aggressively obnoxious
games in recent times comments by
friends and foes alike consist of out of
place observations and terrible sex
jokes that even beavis and butthead
would find embarrassing
was it good for you too you can never
escape this chatter either as you're
constantly accompanied by a veritable
broadcast booth of idiots don't look to
the gameplay to make up for the scripts
deficiencies on the contrary the game is
stripped down to the raw basics
there are just four different types of
characters to choose from at the start
of the game all fantasy archetypes none
can be customized before delving into
the campaign either alone or with three
others it's easy to find a match to drop
into which you can do with just a couple
of clicks from the main campaign screen
you can also readily move in and out of
online and offline play so the option
for something different is always there
adding other players doesn't
dramatically change how you play however
sacred 3 is just the same old same old
whether you're on your own or playing
with others
character progression is weak there are
no loot drops during combat and there's
no inventory kill a bad guy and you're
showered with gold and shining orbs that
boost health and power but you never
earn any artifacts like magical swords
or ancient Helms instead the game doles
this stuff out to you like rations as
rewards for finishing missions and
leveling up without the instant
gratification provided by cool new gear
and enchanted artifacts all of the
clicking is just a pointless grind yay
our troops are helping the ones you
freed keep doing what you're doing as a
result the entire game is played with
just three or four weapons there are
limited slots for amenities like health
potions and shield amulets each hero
comes with default attacks plus shared
special abilities like a bash that can
take down enemy shields and an execution
move that finishes stunned opponents
only a handful of combat arts provide
heroes with added class specific
abilities most of the above can be
upgraded by purchasing branches on skill
trees that offer up added damage wider
attack range and so forth but they're
not easy to come by and some are so far
off in the distance that they seem
unattainable especially in the early
stages of the game
having to get to level 41 to unlock the
barbarians final armor buff which is
just the fourth available is just crazy
sacred three consists of disconnected
levels and wholly separate locales and
dungeons all of which are rigidly linear
enemies are repeated over and over again
in both the story and arena levels much
of the enemy horde consists of goblin
like monsters giant spiders trolls and
the like although occasionally you get
thrown a curveball like gross puking
zombies and ice creatures and when the
rogues gallery gets changed up most of
the differences are only skin-deep as
all enemies seem to rely on just a few
types of attacks
there are some positives here boss
battles at the end of each story level
can be very challenging they often
require you to take advantage of the
scenery to survive or use some arcade
styled gimmick to turn the enemy against
itself battles are frantic whirls of
color showing off some attractive
visuals that fill the screen up with
explosions and magic effects levels are
equally nice to look at with varied
backdrops that range from jungles to
crypts to quasi factory settings sacred
threes biggest problem is that it's
simply so forgettable
it isn't just removed from the previous
sacred games it's all so far removed
from the reasons you come to games like
this in the first place
oh boy
I beloved Gloria we destroyed 20 cities
together